foreign
first of all I'd like to say that I'm
very honored to be here this afternoon
so thank you for inviting me
my relation to Clyde is perhaps more
recent than for many of you I've been
involved in two initiatives in recent
years with Clyde one is a monitoring
Network on ecd that I've thank you
that Clyde initiated some years ago so
and he led for for a few years so we
worked together and I must say that he
was quite quite an inspiring person to
work with and very fun very intense
always and the other initiative and
that's my
starting point is a more recent
demand from the Royal Society of Canada
of a kind of a review of literature a
panel of experts that I had the
privilege of co-presiding with Clyde
many of the the person who participated
the colleagues are are here so and that
was that was great fun I learned a lot
about his capacity for synthesis
so I would describing but the best way
to describe it I think is it was really
a beautiful mind and to me the Mind
includes the soul so
that's for that so what I'd like to do
today is maybe I don't have the time to
talk about everything that's in that's
in the report I would
incline suggest that you read it if you
have time but uh but I'll take the part
the portion that I know most most about
about is the the question of
longitudinal research and what I'd like
to do is simply to describe how the new
generation of longitudinal research can
inform policy
um the uh I use I would use I will
illustrate very briefly uh some of the
results we we got from some of the
cohorts that we've been following in
Quebec uh they are they are Illustrated
here some of we have many cohorts that
we've started over the years but these
are the new recent ones that we've
started initiated in the 1990s around
this time many places in the world you
had these new cohorts that were
initiated uh often birth cohorts but the
idea was to get a more detailed
assessment of the early years the zero
to six uh years so
we according to this we we we started
those cohorts I'll be specifically uh
talking about the the Elder cohorts the
one that is described up there it's a
Singleton cohort and we also have a twin
cohort that I won't be talking about
with this Iran in parallel the Elder
cohort is not by any mean a very
impressive in terms of numbers uh you
have more numerous cohorts that are more
important in in numbers uh elsewhere in
the world but I think it's it's very
it's a very unique chord in the quality
of the follow-up especially in the early
years you have at least six data points
before school entry uh seven if you
include kindergarten
and these are I plan to be Omnibus
cohorts so in the sense that we we
certainly want to assess the the big
Triad that we should be assessing at
that age that is Health uh social
adjustment and cognition School
Readiness if you like
um they they do inform Us in in some
ways uh first of all by by documenting
so these are more informing policy
indirectly by documenting developmental
trajectories so I'll be showing some
examples and also developmental Cascades
and processes so by having the virtual
value multiple time points gives you the
possibility of assessing processes
already before school entry uh and that
allows us to point to sensitive period
of change and possible targets of
intervention but also and that was the
case for ldec it's also if you have
information about the use of services
you can ask you you kind of can act
um evaluate uh the impact of these uh of
these Services over the population and
we were lucky enough to have most of the
kids not both of the kid but a
substantial portion of the kids that
we've started following who were
entering daycare the the daycare system
in Quebec was initiated at about the
same time that we started ldx so that
was an occasion and I will be presenting
uh at least one slide on this
first slide essentially trajectories
what you have here are three examples of
trajectories that could be drawn from
the data collected in the these early
years essentially these are three
examples they could be you could be
others but the point I want to make here
is that these three trajectories they
share at least two two aspects first
there's always a significant small but
significant group of kids who are
showing high levels of either of
aggression of hyperactivity of anxiety
and depressed symptoms of anxiety and
depressions so
each uh type of trajectories they have
their own Dynamic but but you you you're
always finding this small sample of kids
now
this this doesn't mean that this is uh
this won't change uh as you add uh data
points it is likely that you'll have
less and less people on this eye
trajectory but still this is the first I
think important thing to notice the the
trajectory they get established very
early the other thing is that they don't
intersect so once the the trajectory
started it tends to be on the same line
you have individual differences that
tend to be stable
and again the curves can be different
but the these trajectories they are
established very early in life
what you can do too with these uh
provided you get information on the
environment you can model the
environment here with model a pure
relationship which is pure relationship
difficulty essentially victimization
which is uh an environment for the child
what is nice about this is that you you
can also identify a group of kids who
are experiencing and then look at the
predictors and if you look at the
predictors you see that you have some
predictors like individual predictors
but also uh relational or family related
predictors so it's not that you have one
single budget explaining the nature of
things but and the nature of exposition
to environment but there's a variety of
risk factors that kind of get multiplied
by the fact that there's a an addition
of risk factor over time
you can also assess
processes provided you get the the good
information here we looked at the
relation between SCS and School
Readiness which wasn't that great by
uh by any chance we we had about 10
percent of the violence explain uh the
relation between SES and School
Readiness was about 10 so it's not that
that huge but still we could uh connect
explain uh this Association by
essentially exposition to reading so we
were able to show that part of that
associate Association was accounted by
exposition to reading leading to
expressive vocabulary and School
Readiness so it's a way to identify
potential Target for intervention
uh I mentioned that we could assess
interventions or services
a great a great portion of our sample
attended daycare so we could compare
their School Readiness
as a function of attending or not
daycare and here we found an interaction
so we
controlling for all kinds of other
factors that could explain a selection
process we we found that attendance of
daycare
over five years was associated with
increases in or better School Readiness
and but only for family of low education
status so there was an interaction it's
not a general effect that we found
but
in effect for maybe uh family more at
risk which is pointing in the right
direction
so longitudinal studies are telling us
that prevention should start strong in
early childhood before problems get
entrenched through cascading effects
it would persist over time
Universal as we saw but as well as
targeted from other studies preventive
interventions may have sustained
positive impact but policy wise each
approach each approach has its
limitation for instance there are
multiple risk factors to any problem
trajectory problematic trajectory so
that targeting a risk factor leaves many
vulnerable settlement behind so that's a
problem when you're dealing with uh
targeting if we add targeting if we add
targeting children on low SES for
instance we would have left a lot of
children vulnerable children behind
on the other hand Universal
interventions are not necessarily
necessarily access this uh University
it's not bad because you have a
universal program that it will be
accessed equally and a good slide for
this is one taken from the early years
study when they looked that's coming
from the national longitudinal Soviet
children where the compared Ontario and
Quebec in terms of access to EC that was
before the new program of K4 Universal
K4 implemented in Ontario recently but
you could see that overall
if you provide services there's you know
people will
use it but
there's also a creation of uh of uh kind
of a
a gradient associated with income in the
sense that more affluent people will
tend to use the service more so this is
a problem and we should be working
towards
um kind of
trying to solve this difficulty
so
we should be aiming for proportional the
solution to that is that we shouldn't
should not be opposing
a universal program to targeted program
what we need is what was suggested by in
the Marmot report and that Clyde
insisted we we consider in in our report
is proportional universalism that is
program services and policies that are
Universal but with a scale and intensity
that is proportionate to the level of
disadvantage in a given context
so just to finish
two conclusion two concluding remarks
with respect to proportional
universality
to get universality you need first of
all a political will and power to
establish a basket of services and that
will not come easily so at some point
there's a there's a political will and
decision that has to be to be made that
was made in Quebec uh
hopefully it will come in other
jurisdiction jurisdiction in Canada
but then also I think there is a
sequence in the uh event of thing if you
want to move towards proportional
proportional universality I think you
need University universality first
and then work within the universe
Universal system to add proportionality
so there's a sequence to be respected in
that
because if you go for a proportionate
you will never get universality
and for a sustainable policy we need we
need information on the system and you
need an integrated monitoring system and
that was the the the vision of Clyde a
system of Developmental surveillance a
kind of Edis Based On Tools like the EDI
but EDI please going uh maybe earlier in
time to to measure development in
children
and linking linking this to population
data we also need an ecd policy
assessment to measure the uptake of
services by in the population and access
to the services in the population and of
course you need longitudinal studies
this is the the network the the goal of
the network that I'll talk to you about
the firm on Early Childhood monitoring
so I would invite you to visit the site
where the vision of Clyde is laid out so
thank you